I don't think Shevin inquire unless
you're ready to impeach you know and
that's why this we are and I again I've
never asked any members not to do this
that they all do in their own timing of
their own representation what they
believe is right but what I believe is
that when we go forward as we go forward
it has to run deep it can't be the
Democrats and Peach in the House the
Senate in his view exonerate and the
Republicans exonerate in the Senate that
this met President must be held
accountable
so the I feel no pressure from my
members to do anything and I give I have
no pressure on them to do anything this
you were there for a number we will be
having access to less redacted version
of the Moller report I had said
originally unless the whole country can
see what they show us we shouldn't see
it but I have when we had the offer of
this less redacted for many more people
than just the leadership I accepted that
because I'm afraid I really don't trust
the Attorney General of the United
States and I'm afraid that he may
depending on what is in there tried to
shall we say deal with ongoing matters
in a way that is not constructive for
our Constitution I can't say anything
more than that to Taiwan one time one
country two systems' Taiwan's election
but every day the president puts more
grounds forward that says he is
obstructing dust justice and that's what
has affected members they're like the
self-evident that he is obstructing
justice he's ignoring subpoenas article
three of the articles of impeachment for
President Nixon were he did not honor
the subpoenas of Congress but I think
people still want to see the underlying
but as we see what comes out in this
less redacted model report that may
affect the timing mostly
where exactly is the line for you I mean
you've sort of spoken about threats to
the Constitution from this White House
so so when does it rise above all the
other stuff for you what is that well
we've stopped finding even more
information listen as I say with many
this runs deep and every day we see more
so why would we stop with our less
strong case if you're going to go down
this path you got to go down this path
you have to make it so clear forgive me
if I said this already but I say it all
the time so I'm not sure where I said it
left maybe on the phone earlier this
morning if you're going to go down this
path you have to make sure that the
public has an understanding of why and
that when the president if the president
is impeached that the Senate understands
that they either honor the oath of
office to protect and defend the
Constitution of the United States but if
they don't the public will hold them
accountable for not holding the
president accountable some have met some
of proposed censure that after
exhaustive hearings and your information
search if you could not convict in the
Senate you couldn't actually impeach
that the house could for history sake
pass a censure resolution that would
force Republicans in the Senate to say
something about the president's conduct
is this something that you're
considering no I think censor is just a
way out if you're going to go you have
to go
in other words if the goods are there
you must impeach and censor is nice but
it is not commensurate with the
violations of the Constitution should we
decide that's the way to go that's my
view there are a few people in our
caucus who say we could just do that and
that's that's a day at the beach for the
President or at this golf club or
wherever he goes to get that complexion
and I'm so happy to see many women so
many I don't expect the Republicans to
do anything but protect
the president unless the case is so
clear in the public mind